I was the trial judge when Chris Young
went to trial in 2012 that case it was
in front of me I had just taken the
bench about a year earlier and and Chris
was an early trial ultimately I did have
to send him to life in prison it was it
was mandatory my hands were tied
normally a judge has discretion to
fashion a sentence that is sufficient
but not more harsh than necessary to
serve the purposes of why we send people
to prison in his case it was a mandatory
sentence it was gut-wrenching to do that
and to know that there was nothing that
I could do this was just a formality and
as Chris spoke before I sentence him
he's talking about all the things that
he would do is if someday he's going to
get out but we all know that you're not
going anywhere except to the Bureau of
Prisons and so it was it was
gut-wrenching and I think that's part of
it I think about him a lot he's going to
get a chance to speak but I kept feeling
keep talking because the longer you talk
then I don't have to say life it was it
was horrible I had been on the bench for
about six years coming right at six
years and part of what I saw was this
criminal justice system that I thought
was unfair in many ways and particularly
with mandatory minimum sentencing and so
the decision became am i more useful
sitting on the bench which would have
been very easy to do and live out my
life it's a lifetime appointment or is
I'm better serving the public in this
country by stepping down and talking
about these things and working to change
the system and the system can be changed
it's going to take political will but
the mandatory minimums need to be
reduced if not eliminated Chris Young
should be released because we've got an
individual who's now 30 he's done eight
years in prison now
who has served his time he's been
punished for his crime and keeping him
imprisoned longer serves no purpose
other than revenge you know I don't know
what purpose it would serve and so
you've got a young man who really has
the ability to add something back to
society I think the takeaway message
from this is that we are a nation of
second chances people deserve second
chances and we need to find a way to
look and find them and get that second
chance to the people who deserve it and
Chris Young really illustrates that
these kind of sentences are not who we
are as a nation it's not justice for the
person who's sentenced and it's not it's
not justice for the rest of us this
country can do better than that